hey guys it is the 3rd of december today
my name is jess mcdonnell and you're
tuned in to gamespot news
limbo for xbox one is coming in just a
couple of days and it's all set to
impress at 1080p and 60 frames per
second the fantastic indie game from
play dead is going to be available for
9.99 or equivalent xbox exec bill
spencer called the title a must-have so
if you own an xbox and you don't have
the new xbox one version will be
available for purchase on december 6.
the game was technically already
available on the platform as a free
download to people who picked up an xbox
one during the console's launch weekend
gta 5 is just too damn violent according
to target australia who removed the game
from sale the retailers said they
received feedback from customers about
the game's quote depictions of violence
against women which is why they made the
decision to take it off shelves the game
carries an adult's only r18 rating here
in australia but a change.org petition
calling for gta 5 to be blocked from
sale in target stores seems to have
succeeded in their attempt to have the
game removed take 2 ceo strauss zelnick
has said he's disappointed with the
decision and also defended gta 5 calling
it a work of art although its gritty
criminal setting may not always be
pretty
finally a new custom ps4 has hit the
market in limited supply to celebrate
playstation's 20th anniversary the
design which is inspired by the original
psx is super classic with a silver grey
finish and the original playstation logo
there's also going to be a small
insignia noting the unique number of
each unit since only 12
300 are being made in total the console
is available for pre-order from the us
and europe and is priced at 499 bucks
and
499 euros president of sony's worldwide
studios division shuhei yoshida wrote on
the playstation blog the mid-90s were an
exciting time for game developers driven
by the explosion of powerful but
affordable 3d graphics rendering
hardware and the birth of many young and
adventurous development studios the
original playstation was meant to embody
that sense of adventure and discovery
that sense that anything was possible
as for your question of the day let me
know if you had the original playstation
or what your first console was if you're
after more stories you can head to
gamespot where we've got bits on the
last of us movie and nintendo getting
sued by donkey kong for some reason that
is it for me today our us friends will
be taking over for the remainder of the
week but i'll be back to give you some
more news on monday
you